six nominations porcine se maria qui
était présenté au festival de cannes
dont deux nominations qui concerne
directement vos deux comédiennes
forcément leurs électeurs vous êtes ça
vous fait plaisir c'est un film qui a
été écrit spécialement pour pour
questionner et et juliette
c'est un film qui a été inspiré par
juliette et qui au résultat est devenu
le film de deux comédiennes et moi je me
fait extrêmement plaisir que leur
travail soit reconnu aujourd'hui c'est
vraiment ce qu'on peut espérer de mieux
pour un film ça a été une rencontre
incroyable pour vous olivier assayas et
et juliette binoche kristen on s'était
rencontrés au festival de cannes et j'ai
l'impression que ça avait été quelque
chose de très fort pour vous encore
aujourd'hui ça reste très fort oui
absolument
c'est vrai que quand on fait du vrai
travail
il faut qu'on soit sincère et en fait de
ce qu'on a fait était vraiment quelque
chose de réel
c'est pour cela qu'on a cette réaction
est de travailler avec les deschamps
quand même qui nous soutient c'est
vraiment quelque chose d'extraordinaire
c'est un film magnifique sur le métier
de comédienne aussi juliette et vous y
êtes
comme souvent incroyables sincèrement
vraiment c'est un film qui lui aussi
vous tient à coeur pour ces raisons là
aussi sur tout ce que ça dit sur le
métier de comédien c'est rare de parler
du métier d'acteur comme ça et olivier a
écrit un scénario magnifique sur le
métier mais aussi sur le monde quand on
contemporain est ce qu'il faut lâcher ce
qui part avec le avec le passé ce qu'on
regrette mme à la fois il faut aller
vers le nouveau et cette confrontation
des générations alors elle nous amène en
fait vers une certaine gratitude
finalement par rapport à financer le jeu
qui compte c'est le ce qu'on donne
personnellement et qui à l'arrivée c'est
ça c'est quand on va voir les films si
on veut voir les êtres humains et la
merveilleusement écrit kristen c'est une
belle complicité qui vous alliez à
juliette pendant le tournage et encore
aujourd'hui
on est bonne copine qui n'ont pas du
tout et on se prend un petit peu encore
au jeu les césars il ya une domination
et on continue fille n'est ce pas
olivier